our next guess to quit the government in
order to campaign for a second
referendum some came I thank you very
much for being with us it feels with
brexit that sometimes we're just banging
our head against a brick wall and not
getting anywhere so what's your view on
what would be a realistic way to get us
out of this impulse yeah well thank you
well the first thing is I actually
resigned because I couldn't vote for
Theresa made some withdrawal agreement
and I couldn't vote for it because I
think whether you voted leave or remain
no sovereign country can sign a deal
where everything the other side wants
it's an in an international treaty that
is legally binding and everything that
we could possibly want is in a document
that could be reneged on and I think we
were given up a lot and getting nothing
in return that's why I didn't vote for
it and then I began to look at what how
you solve the brexit impasse and the
more I looked at it the more I realized
actually there is no majority for any
brexit option in Parliament and I made
this call back last December and it
seemed to be ahead of the time but if we
look at what's happening over the last
few weeks we've had indicative votes on
all the different breaks and options
that there is no majority for anything
so if there's no majority for any breaks
an option what would happen is if
Parliament came up with anything people
would regard it as some kind of
stitch-up
so if Theresa May got away and had a
customs union deal with Jeremy Corbyn
those who want No Deal brexit would say
that's a parliamentary stick up they
don't want it if two resumes deal went
through those who want no deal breaks it
would say it's a stitch-up and I thought
if that is where we're going to end up
where everyone is going to feel betrayed
then maybe the answer is to let the
people back into the process to actually
say that now that we know what is
negotiable
that they're willing to go ahead in
those terms I mean you say that there's
no majority for anything in the House of
Commons which is clearly true but the
reason there's no majority is because
MPs are just unwilling to compromise
from their positions we can have a
little bit of a listen to what one of
your former colleagues Nick Bowles said
after he decided on Monday to quit the
Conservative Party chiefly because my
party refuses to compromise
I regret therefore to announce that I
can no longer sit for this part I mean
he's right isn't he and you didn't
compromise either did you you didn't
vote for anything no I actually know I
actually abstained on the options
because that if Parliament wanted to
agree on his options fine I think one it
is a long-standing friend of mine but
what we've got to realise is every
different brexit path represents a very
different future for our country those
who want a new deal brexit see the
economic future of our country
ultimately as a trade deal with Donald
Trump those who feel they want to
protect manufacturing jobs in the north
won't a customs union with the EU so if
these are irreconcilable choices about
the future in which were direction in
which we take the country you can't
split the difference you can't split the
difference if you feel that to protect
manufacturing jobs in the Midlands the
most important thing is frictionless
trade so what will you compromise on
them because it feels as if the people
might want to second my friend Irma just
as intransigent is done in France I
think second referendum is not a brexit
outcome it's a process
what would none of us knew at the time
of the refers referendum was what was
negotiable my party set its red lines
not even knowing what she want then
other than a second referendum I mean
most people would say that that is some
people would view that as just a way of
saying that actually you want to remain
but you just don't want to say it and I
would campaign for remain in a second
referendum versus two resumes deal
because Teresa Mays deal takes us out of
the EU but delivers new material
benefits and we've almost got to this
stage where we are saying to ourselves
as a country we just want to leave
irrespective of the deal irrespective of
the outcome irrespective of the future
that represents for us and what I can
see is if we believe in our voice our
veto you know I heard Jacob Riis mark
saying we could veto this we could stop
this we're leaving all that we have in
return for an uncertain future now if
someone was to be able to say to me that
we could deliver what we said we'll
deliver in our manifesto which is we
would have a bespoke trade deal that
will not just preserve the current
benefits but put us in a position where
we did better
then I'm all ears but my position is not
very different to John regular when I
listen to John redwood in the House of
Commons I agree with him on his analysis
of Teresa Mays deal where we disagree is
what do you do about it and what he says
the words the way to deal with it is to
go for new deal and what I see is that
no responsible government should go for
that option now if John redwood were to
come for an option that did not require
disruption that would hurt the most
vulnerable people than most in this
country I'll be willing to sign up to it
okay and now I'm also interested to know
your thoughts on the direction of the
concept of party you gave an interview
recently with evening standard in which
she said amongst other things they argue
the Tory party only talks to brexit ears
it comes across as dismissive of those
who are not when are you worried about
the direction that your party is going
it well I think the firstly brexit are
so dominated everything that when we
talk it's as though the views of those
who voted Breck's that are the only
views that matter we don't even
recognize that even amongst the brexit
ears there are many different views
amongst brexit ears at one event of my
constituency we established there were
seven different views of doing brexit
through our brexit ears but the key
thing is a Conservative Party cannot be
a one nation party can only talk to half
the population I mean you've had some
issues haven't used one with your local
Association you've faced three attempt
to do selections and a vote of
no-confidence I mean are people trying
to get rid of you well that's the space
of and nine years over there is a to
refer to my association there is a small
cabal that always see every election
cycle as a reason to have another go and
and get get rid of me and I've got quite
used to what I knew who they are and you
know some of what I just Phillips the
same has echoes with me undermine things
you do twist everything because that is
their objective so why is that better
why are they trying to who knows I mean
I am the my speculation is that for
saintly from here from what song am I
saying I'm in many ways I'm probably a
step in modernization too far for them
you know I think some of them this
particular group of people have Tory
heads and you
hearts but I made it I made a judgment
call at the start of the when I in this
practice process I spent several years
implementing pressure as a minister but
then ultimately when I saw Tomatoes
amazed brexit deal I said this comes to
the question of what am I in politics
for and we've got to have the guts to
say to people the truth that we see
we're now at a point where we're willing
to go ahead and do things that we know
in some cases are not right because we
can't face telling people that there are
contradictions that doesn't mean we
don't do it but it means people should
be fully aware of all the difficulties
and complexities of delivering brexit
I'll give you one example that I have
challenged with this group of people the
idea of an extension to article 50 and I
say Greenland small Greenland 50
population fifty thousand one industry
fishing it took them three years to come
out of the EEC we are the fifth largest
economy in the world we've been in the
EU which is far more integrated for
forty five years
my argument is the idea that we can
negotiate and come out in two years
doesn't work when I say this people
think you're just trying to frustrate
the process I think I'm leveling with
people on the stark reality of the
situation in which we are it was
interesting hearing you say a little
earlier on so that for some you think
that you're a static modulation I
thought you're good to pick up two and
because it's interesting you were a bit
of a rising star under David Cameron
weren't you you knew you his
parliamentary private secretary you're a
minister now if I want to put him past
this your career now you've felt that
you've had to step back from the
government to join the backbenchers
chief of the Conservative Party has
changed yeah well I didn't want to be
our next Minister and I certainly didn't
want to be on next Minister at this
stage in my career but the country in
the party faced a very different
challenge now - I don't think being a
time serving Minister is what I want to
be I want to be out there unable to
speak up on the big debates of our time
no free trade the future of the party
would have been by the time the next
election comes whenever it comes with
more power for too long what is your
view on the day for the party are
putting brexit aside what what is your
view on them
is it at risk I think it's I think we
the next election will be a time for
change and unless the conservative party
can present itself as the party of
change we risk losing power to Jeremy
Corbyn that is a fact if the
conservative party can only speak to
half the population and ignore the
consents of the other half that is a
problem if the conservative party is a
part brexit party then it's a jammed
radio signal for all the young people
who have very different views of the
future of our country and that will be a
problem for us of the next election if
austerity is followed by a chaotic
disruptive new deal brexit that will be
a stumbling block towards winning power
and in fact all hand power to Jeremy
Corbyn so yes we've done a great job in
rescuing the economy but I feel that the
risks to us are great we need a fresher
party we need a new vision of where
we're going for that we need a vision of
hope what we don't need is where we are
which is just be able to tick the box
mark brexit whatever it means just so we
can see we've delivered I think that
will be let in the country down and a
party that lets the country down cannot
be re-elected